Merhabalar Eren ben
Tetikçi diyor kafelerinin bu yılki
organizatörüyüm
telifli YouTube hepiniz hoş geldiniz
[Alkış]
ilk kez bu kadar büyük bir kalabalığa
hitap ediyorum Son bir haftaya kadar bir
konuşma metni yazmak yoktu Aslında
aklımda sonra birkaç gün kala dedim ki
Eren Sen 450 kişiye konuşma yapacaksın
hemen bir şeyler yaptın
buraya çıkmadan önce konuşmama en fazla
yapabildiğim kişi sayısı yediydi
Genelde insanlar konuşur ve ben dinlerim
ya da bir anda lafa girerim ve hiç Susma
ki konuştuğum bir anı yakalarsınız
çok heyecanlı gerçekten 6 aydır 6 aydır
canla başla çalıştığımız
organizasyondayız şu anda 6
çok uzun bir süre gibi bu süreyi
açıklayabilmek için şöyle örnekler
verebilirim bu sürede Yaklaşık 15 tane
deneme sınavı olmuşuz
20 kere faaliyet yazdırdık ki
kendilerinin bu durumdan ne kadar memnun
olduğu tartışılır
ama belki de
Türkiye'nin dört bir yanından
katılımcıları konuk ettiğimiz bir
organizasyon düzenliyor olsaydı
fikirleri değişebilirdi
bugün Hülya Hanım Babür Bey Nihan Hanım
Selçuk Bey çilemanın ve Taha bey
bizlerle birlikte olacak
Hepsi birbirinden güzel konuşmalar
hazırladılar hiç vakit kaybetmeden
Yine teşekkür etmek
istiyorum etlerimizi kırmayıp geldikleri
için bu organizasyonun bir parçası
oldukları için
Hepsi de aslında bizim en başta bu 6
ayın başında belirlediğimiz bir konuyu
göz önünde bulundurarak hazırlamışlardı
konuşmalarını rezonans
bunların bir
leşerek bir duruma ev sahipliği yapması
olarak tanımlayabiliriz ancak
sezonansın bir tanıma Aslında her bir
ekip üyemizin
canla başla sürekli olarak çalışması
Bizi bugüne geçirdi bu büyük çaplı
durumu oluşturdu size bahsettiğim
saydığım konuşmacılarımızın yanında
Okulumuzdaki seçmelere katılan
öğrencilerimizden bahsetmek istiyorum
birazdan sevgili Enver Ezgi
Irmak Göktuğ Eymen ve armanç büyük bir
cesaret göstererek Okulumuzdaki
seçmelere katıldılar ve birbirinden
etkileyici sunumlar sergilediler
Sevgili Hüseyin Kaya telifçi YouTube
konuşma yapacak Aydın Fen Lisesi
öğrencisi olmaya hak kazandı
kendisinin konuşmasını Dört gözle
bekliyoruz
organizatör olmak hiç kolay değil
tedx bana bunu öğretti Ama bu etkinlik
bana başka ne öğretti biliyor musunuz
aynı şu anda her birinizi gördüğüm gibi
ki göremiyorum ışıktan dolayı
şu anda baktığınız gibi bir şeyler
öğrenmek isteyen gözlere
konuşmaları heyecanla bekleyen gözlere
bakmayı öğretti
O Gözleri aynı heyecana bakabilmeyi
öğretti Buradaki en büyük teşekkürüm
birlerden
katılan etkinlik boyunca Siz de
heyecanımıza ortak olursunuz
bu konuda destek olan kurumlarımızdan
bahsetmek istiyorum
bir açıdan bize destek olan Ortaca final
kuantum kuark Ege Alfa egesel pusula ve
dörtgen eğitim kurumlarına
konuklarımızın ulaşımı konusunda destek
olan kafa eğitim kurumlarına
etkinliğimizin profesyonel kaydı
alınması için yardımını esirgemeyen fen
bilimleri eğitim kurumlarına
ikramları için Oba Pastaneleri ve
Altınbaşak Unlu Mamülleri oldukça
kısıtlı bir zamanda yerel basında
Adımızı duyurmak için elinden geleni
yapmış peron medya'ya konuklarımızın
konuklanması ve ağırlanması için
elinden geleni yapmış yine aynı yere
otele ve aynı zamanda büyük destekleri
için Bahçeşehir Koleji kurucusu Cengiz
altıntaş'a ve son olarak birkaç hafta
içerisinde etkinliğimizin seyrini
oldukça
değiştirmemizi sağlayan maddi ve manevi
konuda bizi yalnız bırakmayan Aydın Uğur
kursa çok teşekkür ediyoruz
her şey başlarken demiştik ki
bu etkinlik Bir Hayli yorucu olacak oğlu
da
Ama yaşadığımız anlar geçirdiğimiz
zamanlar paha biçilemez olacak
sevgili ekibim siz söyleyin paha
biçilemez miydi geçirdiğimiz zamanlar
[Alkış]
Ben de öyle düşünmüştüm
kendilerine büyük bir Alkışla sahneye
davet
etmek için ekibinden Nisa Ayşegül Arda
Zeynep Sena ve Ekinsu sosyal medya
ekibinden Ayşegül Yiğit ve Elif Seval
ağırlama ekibinden Sude Selen Mina ve
Berra teknik ekipten Kayra Adem Ömer Can
ve Mustafa
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Artık sizi de daha fazla bekletmeden bu
heyecanı dorukta bırakarak programımıza
geçmek istiyorum